Hello Freak bitches.
Yeah.
I just feel like,
um,
there's a certain amount of energy that
people get from wanting to prove other
folks wrong.
Yeah,
no,
for sure.
For sure.
And uh,
it can,
it can help you in some ways.
It can certainly help you,
but I think sometimes even like,
what are you talking about the
benefits you had a cocaine,
like there's benefits to it.
There's like you could say things and
do things he ordinarily wouldn't be able
to do.
Well,
this is the motivation of,
of like proving people wrong.
You know,
I'll show you,
you know,
you said I was going to be shit,
I'll show you.
Like you get to a certain point in time
that could kind of play against you too,
right?
Yes.
It could backfire because then it
becomes it for me it becomes like an a,
and I definitely did my last,
not the album I did mom
before last with that,
that angry,
I'll show you quite full
like villain this energy,
you know?
And I was able to make
some really great records,
but it was the most aggressive
music I had ever made.
Right.
And,
um,
some of it was the most
aggressive and a lot of levels,
not even in a mean way,
but just like,
you know,
just the music itself.
Um,
and that,
and I benefited the,
the,
you know,
what I set out to do,
it all benefited,
you know,
but,
um,
I didn't,
it wasn't the normal way I
went about making an album,
so it was weird,
you know,
and,
and it was something that I took a step
backward afterwards and then drop the
second album and like,
all right,
this one's not.
So,
um,
I don't really feel like I'm,
I'm like going,
you know,
up against the masters.
Like I really have
something to prove here.
This is more just like about like
just being at some type of peace,
you know,
and just having things sorted out once
all the madness is all done and just
kinda dislike.
Now it's just like,
right,
right.
You know,
and that's why I did indicat
another satellite flight.
You know,
cause I feel like in the cup was me
just figuring out how to produce,
you know,
and make records and then satellite fight
was me having it mastered and finally
putting together something that was
just like fine tune but in a different
structure where I have like
some instrumentals and then,
you know,
w you know,
the kind of like interludes
and then you know,
records that would just completely,
you know,
format it in different ways.
Maybe not the three verse two Hook formula
and maybe just one long verse in one
altro and you know,
maybe no hook at all,
maybe no drums for the
first minute and 30 seconds,
but there's like wraps,
you know,
just experiment and then try and things,
not that I have that expertise
for creating a record,
you know?
Did you ever,
um,
listened to the brand new heavies?
I know some records here,
the brand new heavies did this
rap thing where they're gods.
It was trying to remember the name of it.
Um,
there's,
uh,
but it was along those lines,
like very experimental.
And this is like back in
like the early nineties.
They did like Kool g rap did one of them.
And did it like to like some
like actual music behind it?
Like yeah,
it was pretty interesting stuff.
But I remember that and
I remember thinking like,
man,
like why don't more people do
like Weird Shit with music?
Like how many people are
thinking the way you're thinking?
Like saying like,
okay,
how about we just do no drums for like
the first minute and a half and then just
start rapping and then the drums kicking
like these kinds of things where you
just like coming up with,
uh,
like just a different approach,
slightly different entry.
I think people are just a little
scared that they'll lose the audience's
attention.
And which is the very,
a real fear.
It's,
I,
I get it,
you know,
but it also goes back
to what I was saying.
Like,
I've just been blessed with a family stat.
you know,
it's into what I'm doing no matter what,
you know.
Uh,
and that's,
that's just dope.
You know,
but the average artist,
no,
they can't just experiment.
And there's this fear where they might
not sell records and then that's bad for
business and this is a business,
you know.
Um,
so,
you know,
um,
it's,
it's understood why most
guys don't really do it.
You know,
I would like to see people do it.
I feel like there's,
that's not an excuse.
I feel like there's a way where people
can be a little bit more creative and
push the envelope a lot
more with the music,
uh,
where it fits in,
in a,
in a way that makes sense.
And it's true to their,
their art and their formula.
I feel like the,
yeah,
there's always a way to try something
new and be innovative and bring something
different to the table if
anybody wants to check out that,
that brand new heavies
that I was talking about,
it's called heavy rhyme experience.
Uh,
and it was the brand new heavies.
It was 92 way back in the day when I was,
I was living in New York and um,
my friend God,
goddammit,
trying to remember his name,
standup comedian told me about him.
He goes,
you gotta listen to this shit.
These guys are doing some weird stuff.
They did a Doula with Kool g rap.
They did a,
one of them with a uh,
gangstarr.
It was pretty bad ass that a
bunch of different collaboration.
So like jazz singers with like rap,
like serious,
like best of the class back then
hardcore rappers rapping over their uh,
their ride or their music.
It was pretty cool.
Well,
AH,
yeah.
Um,
but your,
your point about having the fan base that
allows you to fuck around and practice
and take chances,
that is huge,
isn't it?
Like this,
the mentality that you know,
they,
they like you as a person as
well as like your music so that,
and they want you,
they want to see where you go with it.
Yeah.
You're always going to do your best
know it comes from a pure place to,
no,
I'm not like they know me
as a top 10 single say no,
I'm just trying to make some cool
shit that they can connect with.
And that's the extent every time it
doesn't go beyond that and the minute it
tries to,
it just starts getting frustrating.
Like start thinking about a radio
record to please somebody at the label.
Then it gets frustrating if I started
thinking about this and that for this.
And it gets frustrating if I
keep it just based on like,
amen,
this sounds gnarly and this,
make sure it's not too trippy in this.
Make sure it's not to
this and not do that.
But,
uh,
effortless combination of
everything all at once,
you know?
And,
and,
and that's really what these past
couple of years for me have been like.
Just mastering that
technique is a producer and,
um,
you know,
really,
really just,
uh,
going all out creatively and just trying
new things because I also internally
don't feel like I have
anything else to prove,
um,
as a musician.
But I have that itch,
you know,
like I need to create,
I feel like that's like
working out for me.
It's like doing reps
and stand mentally fit,
creatively fit,
you know?
Um,
so when it comes time to do an album,
I got some new powers I've
acquired in the past year,
just like,
you know,
from just dicking around in the
studio for a couple of months.
It's going everyday and making beats,
whether I'm in the studio
for five hours or two hours,
I'm making something.
I'm making at least like on average
I make about making the studio.
I'm making at least two
to four beats a day.
And when I say beats,
I'm talking about completed,
sequenced,
uh,
instrumentals that I
could make records on.
So like,
not just some shit.
I started a little bit and then it's kind
of cool and I'll get back to it later.
I have probably like a Baker's
dozen of those in one session,
but I'll have like four
that are officially like,
oh,
these jams are dope.
I'm going to sit and live with
these and see what comes up.
So when you sit down to write music,
do you,
do you sit down and do you have an
idea in your head or did you select,
let it come to you while you're there?
Like how do you know how to start?
Um,
it,
it comes different every time.
It,
it doesn't,
um,
it depends.
It could be a baseline that I'm
thinking of it that inspires me.
Or it could be me not have anything
in my mind and just going through the
sounds,
uh,
or it could be like a rhythm are heard or,
you know,
anything.
It could be a movie I'm watching.
I like to,
you know,
produce while I'm watching
movies with the sound off.
Um,
in,
that kind of helps me with scoring.
You know,
when I get in the scoring and the,
you know,
doing as my next step,
I want to get more into scoring
movies and sound design.
Um,
but it's all,
for me,
it's all just experimentation
and just seeing what happens and,
and you know,
it's not any pressure.
And when you hear a beat,
like when you're making a
beat and you're creating it,
you're hearing lyrics.
Are you hearing,
are you thinking about,
yeah,
I'm here.
I mean,
here's,
you know,
when I,
when I'm hearing something,
I hear a completed,
right.
So when I'm starting to record and I
feel like I got some of my right song,
like I feel like in this back
to what you were talking about,
cause you know,
I feel like,
you know,
time doesn't really exist.
So an hour from now is
happening right now.
Right.
So there's songs that are
created that I haven't made yet.
So when I'm in the studio I feel like
I have this small like peek into this
other world in this window
that I can hear the song.
But it's my job in the present to
find the pieces to make it some.
And sometimes it might come out exactly
like what I'm hearing and sometimes it
might not,
but there's never,
it's never really spot on.
And I just hear glimmers of what the
song completed sounds like until it's
completed.
And Dennis just,
everything's perfect.
But that's how I can sit there
and listen to a mix and be like,
something's off.
Because in my completed version,
you know,
it's like a coloring book.
Every record starts off in one way,
just blank.
And I'm just filling in all the colors
and then there's one color is still
missing.
You know,
that's what's happening in the final,
in the ninth in.
And you know when,
when mix knob them,
I mean there's still some colors
that just not in there yet.
And then I'm going through sounds and I
find the colors and everything is full,
then I'm cool or I might not find the
exact color but some close enough I'm
fine.
And like that's literally where it's at,
where you have to make
the executive decision.
Like all right,
I'm done with this.
So I'll be sitting for another two weeks
trying to sit with this mix cause I'm
really anal about it and if I
don't just back away and let it be,
you know,
we'll never hear any news.
That's a fascinating insight
into the creation of music.
So I don't,
um,
I don't know anybody that does that like,
well where they could tell me about the
entire process from the beginning to,
and so it's interesting to get a
window into that world because I always
wondered and I also always wondered like,
I Know James,
he never writes his lyrics down
and it keeps them all in his head.
Right.
Do you do that or do you actually
write them down somewhere?
Um,
Nah,
sometimes I'm sometimes,
I mean a lot of my hooks are in my head,
but I need to write,
you know,
certain things down to just
Kinda make sure I'm making sense.
I used to do a lot of my
earliest stuff just off the dome,
just freestyle and Shit,
you know?
And,
and sometimes that works
good with melodies.
I do that a lot.
I'll go in there and just hum flows
and try different things like that and
melodies.
But it's really just a combination.
It's never the psych,
you know,
always like writing off the dome.
Like some balance.
I'll write completely off the dome.
You know,
I don't need paper for a ballot,
but like if the [inaudible] off the dome,
yeah,
that's a great term.
I'm gonna use that from now on.
Whenever there's a joke that I have,
it's not written down anywhere.
It's going to be off the dome.
Yeah,
that was the end.
I feel like that it Kinda like,
you know,
gets people to understand
that this is some,
you know,
this,
the spontaneousness of it,
you know?
Um,
is that something alternative rappers
use all the time or is that your term off
the dome?
Is that yours?
Oh,
I can't say.
I like to say,
I know the guy came home off the dome.
It's a very popular phrase
amongst the younger now,
but it all came out of kid.
I'll take it.
They get,
I'll start spreading that.
You're essentially,
you're open.
I mean,
whatever,
which way ever comes,
you just show up,
you show up and you put in the work,
you put in the work,
creating the beats you put in the work,
come on,
coming up with lyrics,
whatever way it comes up.
Where it comes up all in your head when
it comes up writing it down on paper and
the sessions are really me and my engineer
in and occasionally I have like my
brother from another mother.
Dot.
The genes coming through who,
you know,
it was an abandoned I came up with
a couple of years ago and that,
you know,
we kind of just put together because we
wanted to try something outside of the
world.
We were already making music in,
you know it's this,
the sessions are really small.
It's not like I got 20 dudes in there.
Right.
They're kind of sad sessions.
They're really sad and probably not sad.
Why was wondering I anything,
you can't feel bad for me like,
oh he's got no money in
the studio all went down.
But then like,
but then like,
you know like I'm in there
like a mad scientist.
Like you know,
I'm inventing right.
It's not like,
you know,
an inventor don't got
20 motherfuckers in his,
his lab.
Why he ain't been shit.
Niggas is still as shit or they'll,
you know,
rack focus and you know,
distract him.
He got.
I find that when you have
your friends in the studio,
you got,
you know,
a couple guys on Worldstar,
a couple of guys on Twitter,
a couple of guys over here and everybody's
talking about what's going on over
here and what's going on in here.
You're trying to write this song,
you get distracted.
You like what happened?
Oh Hell Naw.
That's funny.
Funny.
Next thing you know it's
two hours have gone by.
You still working on this record,
you had some lasts but when you came
to the studio for is not done yet.
Right.
You know,
and there's money being spent in,
there's time.
Time is of the essence.
This is what we hustled
and worked hard for.
You know,
and I have to,
I had to remind myself as like,
man this has turned into a fucking
party and I moved here for work.
So also have this like
really gnarly work ethic.
Like,
cause I've been working since I
was 15 my first job was Wendy's.
I remember why I wanted to work.
It was because I want it in my own shit.
I was tired of asking my mom for stuff
and also didn't think it was fair,
you know,
to ask my mom for stuff because
I know we didn't have much.
So,
you know,
I just had that work for me is always
like one of those things that's very
important.
Yeah.
But like there was also some jobs
that I didn't fucking take seriously,
like American apparel,
you know,
where I was like coming in
late and I didn't give a shit.
And then like when my boss fired me,
like he took me to like this office and
kind of told me and when he said he's
like,
I'm gonna have to let you go.
I was like,
yeah,
I figured that they knew it
because I didn't give a fuck.
You know,
it was like,
I now I can go to the studio.
Well it's probably not,
can make it work and like work on my
craft and then maybe find a better paying
job.
You know,
it doesn't have me in the fucking
basement of some building,
you know,
sweating my ass off phone,
clothes.
Everybody says you should always
do your best at every job you do.
A champion in life is a
champion and everything they do.
So if you're going to mop floors,
do your best,
and my pores Motha fuck
out of those floors.
That's great on paper.
But the reality is when
you're a young man,
it's sometimes it's good
to fuck off at something.
So you know,
you don't ever want to do that again.
They fire you and then you
learn and there's some,
there's some value in that.
It's unfortunate,
but we don't all learn the best way.
Sometimes we got to get
fired from American apparel.
Yeah,
yeah.
At least I didn't get fired
for like stealing something.
I got fired for being a Shitty landscaper.
Scalping people's lawns that
will fuck somebody as emotions.
I would hurt my feelings if somebody just,
if that was like the word
around town that I've been,
you know,
my main bread and butter I've been doing
invest in my life and just shitty yet
feelings.
Yeah.
I wasn't invested in being a
landmark toddler boy landscaper.
Yeah,
I know.
I know what you're saying,
man.
It said there's a completely different
thing when you're creating your own
stuff.
We were working for yourself.
Then it's like a focus,
like an obsession,
almost type focused,
like the laser beam.
I love that term.
The lab too.
That's one of my favorite
terms from the rap,
the rap world.
They love talking about being in the lab,
creating material who are
like an inventor scientist.
You know,
it's,
it's Kinda like I treat it and
that'd be sense of the word.
And every since that,
that,
that term I asked me know lab,
it's like where I'm working,
it's working and almost don't like playing
around and in the studio like that,
like,
cause it is a place for work.
It is an office,
you know,
especially if you're trying to write,
if you're trying to write
things there too as well.
He tried to write lyrics and dudes are
all jumping around and not even that.
What if I'm not even
just me sitting there,
I might not have an idea yet,
even if I might just in silence.
Right,
right,
right.
I might just need fucking
silence for a little bit.
Yeah,
I don't,
I've never been to any sort of a
recording studio where anybody was doing
anything like serious like that.
But I would imagine it's very
difficult to avoid the party.
It's like,
Hey,
we're in studio and guys
come to visit you come on by,
come to visit.
We did that.
So it's like I did that now it's like,
I mean I was,
I've been doing that's like do music
professionally since like 2123 going to
studios and having those moments with
the bugs because in the beginning it's
like you want your boys around.
So I kind of got that out of
my system and now it's like,
all right,
30 year old Scott goes
with studio by himself.
He's got his book bag,
he's in there for maybe five,
six hours and then he goes home that
smart and you know what I'm saying?
And then he's like Friday night,
you know,
like,
and good for you in bed by
like 11 1130 and Kapow Fuck,
sorry.
That's beautiful.
Yeah,
no may man.
That's how you get shit done.
That is how you get shit done.
I'm just psycho.
We didn't man those music videos though
when they showed the recording studio,
it's always a giant table.
There's like all those little
switches that nobody understands.
Maybe you get a mixing board.
Everybody's,
everybody's standing in front of all the
switches and then everybody's partying.
Everybody's in the background,
having a good time.
But that could also be when the
album's done and then celebrating it.
Cause that's what also happens.
Like when I'm done with,
say I finished maybe eight songs
and I feel like I've got the album,
like,
and I just need maybe a couple more jams.
You start inviting people to come here,
which you got and get their hands.
So you had those moments too.
So you might see that happen and,
but,
but there's a year and a half of just
studio by myself before that happens,
you know,
like I don't really,
and maybe a case that happened,
one or two friends,
you know,
maybe some,
one of my director friends are,
um,
my fellow actors.
So I just kinda want,
who have never really got
a chance to have been in,
be in the studio,
come by and just see,
get to experience.
But they're not in,
they're distracting me.
They're just watching and paying
attention and want to just be a fly on the
wall.
See how it works.
Yeah.
Well a lot of people were really
curious about it cause it's a,
it's almost a sort of a mysterious type
of creativity if people aren't involved
in especially the creating of music.
It's such a cultural,
uh,
it's such a cultural influence.
So it's such a powerful influence.
Like your music has,
it inspires people.
Like when you listening
to music at the gym,
it can make you work out better.
Like you put your headphones on
and you play some awesome songs.
You don't give a fuck that you're
on some stupid stamp machine,
like a hamster.
You just keep going.
And then music,
you liked the music so much.
You get into it and it's only,
it's in your head,
drowning out everything else.
Sometimes you don't even realize
how heavy your breathing until you,
you know,
you take the earplugs out,
you're like,
Holy Shit,
I'm getting it in working here.
It's because of nothing else
like hits you like that.
Like people's words,
they don't sustain that way.
You can't like read incredibly passionate
essay and it sustains you through a
workout like that.
Yeah,
no,
it's like,
it needs to be just something that like,
there's nothing like
music in that respect.
It has,
it has an impact that very few things do.
So that,
that process of creating it is always
fascinating and mysterious to people like
me that don't have any
musical talent at all.
Yeah.
I,
um,
I just approached it in a different way,
uh,
because I'm,
I'm just,
I do feel like I'm just,
every time I'm in the studio,
it's me just,
you know,
trying to create the,
uncreate it and it's a very
private thing sometimes.
You know,
I want to,
I want to be able to,
you know,
have my privacy when I do that.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
No,
I totally do.
You do all your writing and everything
and the studio or do you sometimes sit at
home?
Oh,
it comes whenever a man,
right.
I'll be in the shower.
Do you have any of the shower?
I'm thinking of some shit,
you know,
give a,
use that a note app on the phone,
on your phone where you're talking to it.
Um,
record memos.
Yeah,
a lot.
A lot of the time.
Not even that.
I mean the note app,
you know,
you can talk to it and
a voice recognition.
None of them.
I just kind of see if I'm
recording something as a melody.
Okay.
If I'm thinking of some missing mail,
I'm not like thinking of
wraps like other days.
It's less about that now
and it's more about like,
um,
like melodies and coming up
with songs and structure.
You want to hear the sound and then the
lyrics come next because the music is
just going to tell me what to say,
you know?
Wow.
That's,
that's fucking wild.
That's so cool.
Now how much of your creation is done
under the influence of marijuana?
Man,
I don't smoke to create,
I've come up with a lot of Shit's
sober sometimes when I'm fresh,
waking up in the morning.
Like sometimes the most ideas that like
8:00 AM sometimes people say that a lot
of writers like Stephen King I believe
does all of his writing in the morning.
I think he doesn't like
nine to noon every day.
It's like man,
I'm fresh in the morning with something,
some melody.
And it usually comes as walking through
the house and making breakfast and you
know,
it could be whenever it dropping a Deuce,
you know,
I'll come up with just melodies here
and there and I record them all if
something really catches me.
Cause if I don't record them
immediately and not lose them.
So I,
you know,
I got to record them somehow.
But it's,
it's very,
um,
I'm always,
I'm always thinking about music as much
as like I like to deny it and you know,
go shoot a movie and shit.
And you know,
I always think about music.
I'm obsessed with the idea of just making,
you know,
the most beautiful songs that like,
really make people feel some type of
comfort or some type of understanding
because the world is so fucked.
And uh,
you know,
I just really am obsessed with that idea.
I think I'm always going to be,
and now I'm just trying different,
different ways of doing that.
You know,
we did the rap shit,
we did the rock album.
No,
I'm just trying to be this
like weird instrumentalist,
you know,
and I don't really know
when that's going to be,
but I'm just really,
I guess in the process learning
how to produce better too,
which is,
uh,
is something that,
you know,
I've been trying to,
I always want to be better,
so it's good to be learning and
getting better as I'm creating.
Do you do any other things
like other than music,
do you have any other hobbies or things
that like I'm also get locked into a,
I like design and sometimes like,
uh,
and I wouldn't look at myself
as like a fashion designer,
but you know,
if an opportunity comes around
I'll do a collaborative.
You like designing clothes?
Like,
yeah,
like I've done a five t shirt,
collaborations with bay,
the name.
Um,
I used to work there.
That was my last job before I got famous,
you know,
so like I have,
roots back in New York and that
was pretty much one of those,
the only job I've really kept
in touch with and you know,
that I went back to and,
you know,
did some things for the fans.
So you just saying up creating shit.
Yeah,
it doesn't,
yeah.
You know,
it really,
for me,
I'm starting to write a little bit more.
It's just staying creative,
right?
Like realizing like a
book or like blog entries.
Like what do you mean?
Like a TV show or TV shows,
horror movies,
uh,
ideas I've had in my head for a while.
I'll just start jotting them down and,
you know,
just everything right now it's just me
just expressing whatever comes to mind,
you know,
uh,
anything that creatively strikes me.
Yeah.
See,
that's a dream job for people to be
able to just come up with things all the
time.
Just work on creating your,
your entire day spent.
Mostly just concentrating on creating.
I'm not doing anything with those things.
Yeah.
But it's,
it's stimulating,
you know,
it doesn't mean that I'm going to have
some TV show tomorrow or up or anything,
or it's just for me,
it,
it just,
it's stimulating,
you know,
and,
and Shit,
knowing me,
I'll fuck around on my right,
the next shit,
you know,
like,
or something that could
lead me to assumption going,
who knows?
But,
um,
and it probably also helps you,
your,
your creativity in the
other areas as well.
Right.
But then on top of that,
I was the king of being like,
Oh,
I have this idea,
but Nah,
that's not for me.
Or No,
I couldn't do that.
Um,
I,
music is my thing.
No,
I couldn't do that.
So now I'm like pass that now.
There's nothing if it pops into
my mind and I can fucking do it.
Cause I thought about it for a reason.
So now it's just about finding time for
certain projects and I'm not no rush.
You know,
I been worried about being pigeonholed.
You're saying?
No,
I think,
I think I've done enough
strong arm and then let me get,
you know,
my space as an artist where I can kind
of do whatever I want now at this point
she reached out to me.
I just want us to be good though.
Don't get me wrong.
Like I'm always feeling like I'm
vulnerable to make some bullshit.
I don't feel like I'm invincible.
Like,
and I think a lot of artists do get to
that point where they feel invincible.
Like I am very capable
of making some weak shit.
Y'All motherfuckers don't hear it.
And you know,
and who you ask because I'm sitting there
and making sure that this is not weak
shit and scrapping the ones that are and,
and,
and working on the ones
that started off weak,
but you know,
making sure that they were where they
needed to be before you heard it.
Um,
do you have there,
are they like,
you gotta know when to abandon them?
Oh yeah.
You all know when to abandon some shit
immediately and certain feelings you get,
you know when some shit is the
right one and when it's not this,
there's jokes like that too.
Very similar.
Yeah,
very similar.
Some of them you just kind of let go.
Yeah.
And then you can't infer songs.
Some,
it's much more emotional to let go some
shit that you like because it might be
on the right track to being something
gnarly like the shelf maybe he visited.
Yeah.
I go back every year.
I go back and listen to the shit
that I made the year before.
How do you categorize them?
Do you,
do you make notes or do you need,
they're all numbered.
[inaudible] numbered.
You just say you go back and you go,
okay,
this is from 2013 then we just
listened to what I was doing.
My,
my engineer,
I'll just tell him,
pull up everything and we'll just
listen to things one by one flag.
The ones that are good and
are there ones that you know,
cause that's the thing.
You always got to give
yourself a break and uh,
it's always good to listen
to stuff with fresh years.
I find.
And,
and also,
uh,
to just give you your,
your brain a break because for me,
I'm sitting in the studio for hours
listening to the same old shit,
like the same old beat,
you know,
that you're working on,
so it's kind of like you need
to back off a second and like,
I like to work on a record,
bounce him,
whatever,
you know,
bouncing means kind of compressing all
those sounds to one track to make that MP
three.
That's what you bounced on a file.
That's what you guys get on your,
um,
iPods is a bounce down file
of all of all the files.
Um,
so I bounced down everything.
Uh,
every one of the ones that I feel
like we're close to being finished or
reasonable enough for me
to listen to and write too.
And um,
I won't to him that night.
I'll wake up the next day and while I'm
making breakfast on my listen to him,
then with fresh ears and I'll be like,
aw shit.
Most of the time it's like,
oh,
this is dope.
Because the night before I'm just saying,
hi,
this shit sucks.
I don't know.
I listen to it tomorrow,
you know,
cause I've been in an hour,
I've been in the studio for hours,
be too close,
I'm by myself and I don't
have nobody to tell me like,
Yo,
that shit was fresh.
It's just like me and my own expertise.
And just like right now
I think this is all shit,
but I'll bounce it down and I'll
listen to it tomorrow and see.
I feel,
and almost every time I do that,
if I bounce it down,
it's like dope.
And a lot of this shit could be
for someone else and not from me.
Do you?
It's a,
it's the thing about music too,
it seems like when there's a song
that I really like at any genre,
it's like a really like it,
I like it at first and then
I started really liking it.
When I keep hearing it,
I hear it a bunch of times.
Then as I'll hear it like
the fourth or fifth time,
that's what I'll really get into it.
Yeah.
And it's interesting how music does that.
Like there's,
there's songs that you need
to hear a bunch of times.
That's why people don't like new shit.
Like if the rolling stones go on tour,
like they better play
those fucking classics.
Yeah.
Nobody wants to hear some
weird shit even right.
And Keith.
Yeah.
And that's good.
I learned,
I learned the hard way.
You know,
you go out and you do
Coachella and it's like,
all right,
I got fucking Coachella to do this.
Come with the hits this,
give him this,
give him the joints.
Didn't want to hear,
you know,
I'm not going to go out and
the Coachella and be like,
all right guys,
so I know you guys know these songs
as they are produced on the album,
but we're doing them all acoustic tonight.
We know and I'm doing them
all in different keys so
they won't even be formatted
how you remember them.
But I promise you,
you have me tonight on this stage for at
least an hour and a half my stroke and
it's just the worst show ever,
you know?
Yeah.
When you'd go and do a new show,
like if it's totally new thing,
do you do are smaller clubs you
fuck around with like rock club?
What were you talking about?
Like,
like if you're going to work like the
first time you're going to do a live
perform,
can any of you new stuff,
material,
tour,
tour.
Because the tour is like,
for me it's the fan club.
You know,
I could go up there and fumble as many
times I want all night and my fans are
just like,
it's all good.
This is the club house,
right?
This is where you're supposed to fuck up.
You know when you go and do Coachella,
there's no time.
There's no time to fuck up.
Everybody's watching.
It's like the club houses we dick around.
It's like,
you know when a comment
goes to like the cop,
the,
the um,
the club used to do standup at before he
blew up because he knows those are his
people,
that he could be himself there
and you can try new jokes,
you know,
that's the same deal.
Like that's how I approach tour.
You know,
I don't let press in
unless they buy a ticket.
You want come to my show and
then fucking buy a ticket.
Cause most of the time you give the
press their ticket in their writing and
talking Shit said you giving motherfuckers
a free pass to come see your shelter.
They can talk shit.
It's like,
no asshole.
You want to talk shit about my show?
You're going to pay for it.
People feel later,
can't get any attention
unless they talk shit.
That's a,
that's a big issue with folks.
But it's like,
uh,
like,
you know,
whatever the case may be.
I'm gonna make you work
hard to get in there.
So talk shit because it
is a fucking membership.
It's like the only people I want on my
concert of people that really give a shit
about what we're doing as artists,
you know,
and,
and you know,
understand me as a human being,
you know,
so let's say a very
psychedelic point of view.
Yeah.
I mean cause it is at the end of the day,
like we were talking about before,
it's all an experience,
you know,
and,
and the show was even more so because
it's bringing the songs to life.
Like I'm there,
it's like a play for me theater.
Like I'm out there,
I'm,
I'm the showman for tonight
and I'm taking you to a place,
it's kind of like leave
your worries behind.
Yeah.
It's like,
I don't really want kids that,
you know,
the average hip hop show,
it's like you see your favorite artists
come out at best performing the heads.
They're almost there,
but you can't touch them.
But it's just dope to know that
you're in the same building with them.
And then that's the end of it.
And that's just what you take is like,
man,
it was,
we were in the nosebleeds,
but it was really nice.
We was,
you know,
there tonight would that my
favorite rapper or whatever,
this shit with me,
it's more therapy.
I'm confessing some things through song.
You see me,
you know,
confess these things.
You could see the emotion
as I'm performing,
you know?
And then there's kids out there that are
connecting with it in such a way where
it's like,
man,
I already connect with this dude.
But he's performing it in such a
way where he means it even more.
He's singing it in a way where he
means even more in this environment.
You know?
It's like,
it's a different experience.
And I love giving people that experience.
You know,
I love connecting with
them in a way where,
you know,
everybody at that concert is paying
attention and they're there because they,
they,
they want to experience something.
Okay.